i i've got to ask uh before we jump into
some of the viewer questions like
getting getting i mean you've worked
with everyone first off um
and that was my favorite i loved you did
a podcast with theo vaughn and he like
asked if you worked with cat williams
and you're like dude
trust i've worked with every black
comment
you're just like why that that lets me
know
there's a huge divide between mainstream
and black comedy
because i watch i watch rogan's podcast
also
and he had no idea that kevin
dave chappelle chris rock and eddie
murphy had dinner
like two years ago and they posted on
social media and everybody's like wow
that's an iconic dinner to get everybody
together and for some reason dwyane wade
and gabrielle union
yeah but uh
joe had no clue and sometimes he'll have
like black comics on
his podcast and or like when i was with
theo
um it's like they really are not in that
world
you know at all and i was like how did
they i'll be watching like how did they
not know that
like when theo asked me have you ever
met kat williams i go
we open might i know what he was cat in
the hat was one
tooth and he had the furry kango
and he had the biggie joke he ended his
show with the biggie joke and i'm like
do i know him yeah
i would just i would take him back what
yeah what what is that divide because i
mean i've noticed it too
i mean coming up in primarily the urban
side of comedy and i can
i can perform on both sides and like if
a joke works on one side not the others
i kill it like i want to make the comedy
universal but i have noticed i mean
it's like comedy and church are the two
places that are still like
super segregated like that
i don't i mean i don't know i gotta i
always tell comedians like you don't
choose your audience they choose you
hmm you don't choose them you just go or
people and i also think a lot of times
uh
white comics are they're a little
intimidated by
an all black room so they're like i
don't i don't i don't even want to do
that
but like you said if you're yourself and
you're authentic
yep i saw sebastian minnekowsko rip
fat tuesday one night rip and it was
just sebastian
mm-hmm and that's right this is probably
i bet you 14 years ago
and when i saw it i go oh that guy's
good
he just went and it there was a time
where fat tuesday was the tuesday night
spot
in um in l.a it was at the comedy store
that's where all the urban actually
that's all the lakers hung out you'd see
you see all the rappers all the athletes
there that was the spot
right all the hose was there obviously
so
we always beat that out we'll keep it a
hundred yeah yeah
the ball players go i don't know who
comes first but of course all the
chicken heads wobbled in there yeah i
mean
yeah looking for there's a lot of girls
working really hard not to work
i'll put it out um
so uh there was a time though where
they were really starting to like bring
in the iconic
like white axe to do fat tuesday every
now and then like i saw dice clay go up
there
uh then dice was nervous that's the
first time i seen him nervous
what he went from that urban room and he
killed
he went back to the old hickory dickory
jokes and [__] like that
and i was i was watching going oh he's a
little nervous
you know what i mean this isn't his
audience like they announced him and it
was like this
but it wasn't like what he's used to
yeah you know but it
listen he did fine it goes both ways um
judd apatow saw me in nashville
and in front of my fans my audience and
i killed and then he did he does this
charity thing at the largo
on la cienega all the time any charity
comes up he does these big events but he
brings in like sandler
and just you know david spade he'll
bring him back
or like eddie better will come jam out
he does these crazy [__] at the largo
but it's all for charity so he he asked
me to go up one night
and it was not my audience it was the
white california and i had to go last
after sandler
and i go what so i got there
and it was i got a picture of myself
norman mcdonald
um what's what's the guy that god damn
it
he's uh i don't know what his ethnicity
is indian or something he just did uh
the movie on netflix with issa rae
kumail camille yeah yeah i'm sorry i
brain farted no your mail was on the
show
uh adam sandler judd hosted
a couple one other guy and i thought i'm
first
when i got there and joe was like now
you're gonna close it out they go what
and then adam goes i'm dude i'm just i'm
just [__] around just gonna do a
couple goofy songs and [__]
dude it was like
watching the crowd reaction
was like watching jordan the bulls play
and then right after that
a jb high school team came out right
like they went ballistic when adam got
announced right
and of course they were with them for
his goofy songs and i came out there
and it was it was great because i i got
him
it just took about 10 minutes but then i
i brought him like into my world right
but it wasn't like the same reaction as
an urban audience but it still was fine
and everything was cool in the end but i
was just thinking man
if that would have been 15 years ago i
would have freaked out
yeah but now i'm like okay
the first ten just chalk it up to the
game because they're coming off the
sandler high and i gotta
bring them down and then kind of bring
them into my world and stuff
so that's important for like comics to
yeah a lot of times if you're following
someone that kills especially like just
use an example from the urban world if
you follow a comic that does a bunch of
music cues and closes with some big
audience
interactive dance and then you gotta go
up there you know
you got to remember you could tell
you've been in atlanta
that's an elec it's like when i think of
me and like open mic and coming up yeah
i think in my when i've seen chicago has
the strongest
as far as just comedy and jokes
like a lot of guys you haven't heard of
like well that's really good
atlanta i think music bits i think if
you're on the show in atlanta at a
comedy club
who's ever gone to before if you got two
or three guys going for you
somebody's doing some music bits trust
me
but here's what i do i don't come out i
said you try to close with the music bit
and i've learned this over time
and then try to bring me right up i'll
wait a minute
two minutes i'll just sit in the green
room and they'll walk into it
you're up like i know i'll be up in a
minute
i'm gonna let that audience breathe yeah
you know what i mean
that's yeah that's that's smart yeah
it's letting the audience like you said
following sandler and then letting the
audience pick up on your pace i think a
lot of younger comics
try to match the pace of the comic
before them
but yeah and acknowledge it acknowledge
the i acknowledge like sandler i go boy
i know you guys are
thought i said something like i bet you
felt like jim carrey was next
cause this [__] kept going up and up i
go nope
and i said i i even said i'm really
famous of black people
and we only have two mixed people here
tonight and there was like two mixtures
in the audience i go
fine i got one fan here hilarious
what's going on around you you know that
but that comes with with time
don't try to just go like oh this is my
best joke i'm gonna hit it but i think
you're right we try to match the energy
instead of like letting audience take a
breath take a breath
yeah i love it all right yeah and i
think that that kind of ties into our
first question
um oh and uh mitt wolfe is from chicago
and he said yay yay
chai town so yeah okay
thanks man word
[Laughter]
um oh bobby j said all this goat talk
right now got my head spinning cool
goat yeah goat talk we worked with sheep
back in the disney didn't you
who didn't you work with sheep you had a
summer job where you were working on
sheep or something yeah
yeah the lamb lambs oh okay
damn co-op yeah no i think it was chief
was the steep club
it was uh i was in an ffa in high school
future farmers of america uh-huh and i
worked
strawberry farm my summer going into my
sophomore year high school so after my
freshman sophomore
but i also there's anybody that was in
ffa that didn't live on a farm they had
a
okay sorry about it somebody's calling
they had a sheep co-op
um yeah it was cheap one land you're
right oh
sheep nice all right and i was so
mad because i raised six of those sheep
that summer
while i was picking strawberries so i'm
the one that was feeding them
bathed them i sheared them i sheared
them so it wasn't it goes to sheep
because
goats don't get sheer the sheep they i
sheared the sheep
and then we go the fair and the other
five kids that didn't have sheep they
all just we
drew numbers out of a hat dude i picked
like
mo my number was the most malnourished
sheep
and when you're showing sheep okay
the sheep's here and they the the uh
the judge is doing he does this type of
[__] and you go you can't ever be on the
side of judge so when he's there he's
always got to get a good look at the
sheet he can't be blocking the sheet
and i remember just thinking god he's
like frowning at my sheep
man and then one one of the sheep got
like fifth place
in the county fair and i was so pissed
because like i raised that sheep
i go that chick had nothing to do with
that [__] sheep
that was my sheep i wanted that
fifth place ribbon man [__] i love
i love how personal you still take it
you're like man that was it that was my
big break
that was my seat man i was looking there
so and um and bringing in some of the
young comics uh watching here i think
this is a good one to start with here um
this is from amanda oh asking how did
you
find and refine your comedic voice
i mean you kind of every comic's
different
it just has to be organic you just the
more you get on stage the more you find
your voice the more you find your
cadence
your delivery what's working for you
uh it's just it's almost like if you ask
a comic how
how did you make it or quote unquote
make it or where was your big break
every comment's gonna give you a
different story it's just
stage time is the key to all this that's
why i say don't go
don't take comedy classes when people
like
take them long five-week comedy classes
i'm like this the only way you get
better is get on stage
yep that's the only way you know
that's it you can take a class like how
do i
structure a joke or write a joke but in
the end
it's just stage time everybody's
different yeah i think it can help
with like learning techniques and taking
off the learning curve of actually
learning how to write funny stuff
but you've got to take it to the stage
you won't be funny in the mirror you've
got to learn the language on stage
that's it it's the only way to get
better yeah thanks for watching hot
breath the verse
if you want to support the show go join
our patreon but if you don't like
supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click to watch more videos to
keep us alive
in the algorithm hot breath